yeah we had we had the michelin star
ramen oh yeah we did and it was very
exciting we didn't know it's michelin
star right so there's a yeah it was the
place man recommended to us yeah yeah
was it ramen because i i thought it was
sober no it's ramen it's like chu kasoba
which is like chinese server which is
like technically some people call it the
noodles were more ramen noodles
it was very light for a ramen it was
very like it was like when i when you
said like ramen i was just like oh it's
going to be a heavy ramen because
ramen's the kind of meal that like takes
you out it knocks you out for like an
hour but yeah heavier too it's like it's
like a thin noodle wrong
it was good it was like you know when i
was thinking about it i'm like okay what
do i i think i have the wrong
expectations of michelin star i think i
expect some kind of stupid luxurious
like gourmet thing but i guess it's more
about value
yeah it was like a thousand yen i like
the one i got was like 10 bucks yeah
yeah i mean like eight dollars right i
guess yeah like it was amazing i have a
picture of it it was it was very good
but the whole time i was thinking i was
like i think tsukemen is more tasty
though i think so i think so as well so
i'm saying
the bog standard tsukemen uh which uh is
was better than the michelin star robin
i agree honestly i i didn't enjoy the
ramen that much and
okay because here's the thing right i
feel like michelin star if you've been
to enough of them especially in japan
because it's like in japan there's so
many michelin star restaurants but i
i've realized that you cut with michelin
star you come in with like the wrong
expectations right yeah and this is
going to make me sound you know this is
going to make me sound so [ __ ]
privileged you know
michelin stars aren't all that great
about michelin star it's the michelin
star but like here's the thing the
retirement no
like here's the thing when you go into a
michelin star restaurant your
expectations are like up here you're
like scott knows all well because he
often frequents the michelin star of
course of course no but like you you you
come in with these expectations that you
you're gonna get like a meal that's a
cut above the rest yeah right and so you
start judging things harsher than if you
just go to this random restaurant and
just like
find out that there's like amazing food
because in japan i feel like there is
just as many restaurants that have food
that are like michelin star quality that
just haven't been discovered yet you
know and i've and
to me like michelin star isn't always
the indicator of this is the best meal
that you can get in japan what it only
means is that it's it's become famous
enough that people have started to
notice it but there are so many there
are so many hidden gems and like for
example with the michelin star ramen
that is not like the best even the best
ramen that i've had
i've had like
i've had like sketchy ass places
yeah i i i honestly think the uh the
insect ramen i had for my video was
actually better yeah
and that has a hundred times it's not
[ __ ] on the structure
we haven't named the ramen place because
i also don't want to like [ __ ] i'm
saying that because the insect ramen was
actually [ __ ] amazing no and and also
like because it's michelin star it
actually made it a worse experience for
me right because because because you
wait in line because expectations are
too high right one yet your expectations
is high and two it's really really
[ __ ] busy right so in this ramen shop
it's a tiny ass ramen shop it's it's
like when we say michelin star it's a
really it's a normal ramen shop right
ramen stores in general are like not i
would say that good dining experiences
yeah like you it's not it's like if
you're if you want to come here and
chill out with your friends don't go to
a ramen it's a come in eat and go yeah
yeah yeah i mean that place only say to
like what 10 12 people maybe yeah yeah
it's busy it's like narrow you're like
if you're even remotely large then
larger than normal you're gonna have a
tough time
squeezing past everyone
we went at about 2 p.m so not even like
not even close to peak time and we still
have to wait like a good 20 minutes like
20 minutes and this is this is when the
country is closer tourist so when
tourists come back in i was talking to
some people who've waited for this ramen
for like an hour an hour and a half two
hours right and you get you get you get
shepherd in and then you you're expected
to just eat the ramen and leave right
there's there's no there's no downtime
you get given a bowl you eat it and then
leave you going like to me part of like
the food experience is just
like not feeling pressured to eat the
food but just yeah but just like feeling
like i can take my time to enjoy this
food yeah i couldn't i couldn't even
like bask like as good as the ramen was
i couldn't bask in it because i there
was the pressure of oh i could take my
time with this but i'd also be pissing
off the 20 other people still waiting in
line exactly right standing outside this
is why i've realized that ramen is best
at like midnight yeah you can just like
because they they always say they always
serve beers everyone's having like a
good time in there like it's a way more
fun atmosphere like some of the stores
that open 24 hours normally have a few
more seats as well it is the ultimate
midnight snack
it's
honestly it's awful for your stomach
there's a good chance you might like
bring it back up but yeah but
some of the best ramen experiences i've
had are like midnight we're in like a
sketchy area of some place in japan
everyone's drinking beers in the store
it's a cool atmosphere everyone's
talking it's so much more fun than ramen
during the day where everyone's just
there to eat and get out yeah the best
the best ramen experience i had was when
i was absolutely shit-faced
yeah at like 2 a.m and then my friend
makoto was like
like 2 a.m and i was like uh okay so we
ran around the corner to this like awful
sketchy place like the ramen wasn't even
that good but just like it's just fun
it's just fun like when the moment it
went down i was like damn good to feel
alive but then the moment you walk out
it's like oh it's awful all right yeah
because you've ruined your stomach with
you i'm not gonna die now because
because to me like the restaurant
experience goes beyond just the the
taste of the food right there there's
like a reason why your mom's cooking
always tastes [ __ ] good right it's
cause it's cause like because cause that
cooking means something to you you you
you know you know where's the heart man
what's the heart in the brain honestly
honestly you can taste in some japanese
restaurants where they put the heart to
the cooking oh yeah and like it's so
obvious with some like very small
i mean i i just think that i just
i realize that i don't like ramen as
much as i want to like ramen like oh no
like i i uber eats men on sometimes all
right and that [ __ ] is [ __ ] good
because because also ramen travels
terribly that's why never ever order
ramen it's i mean unless you have like
one of those really old star ones where
they like bring you the actual bowl with
everything that's that's the only one i
get problems nowadays with ramen with
ubereats they separate the noodles and
the broth so these give you a broth and
like a plastic really yeah a lot of the
time yeah they don't actually put the
noodles in you have to put the noodles
in yourself
yeah it's not good and the noodles
supposed to be like piping hot in the in
the broth so it doesn't really work but
it travels pretty oh like pretty okay
because you well it's because the broth
is so thick it's like magma yeah the
broth is so thick it stays really hot
and the noodles are supposed to be
separate anyway yeah and then you just
dunk the noodles in and it's almost as
good yeah no i wouldn't say it's
definitely better but yeah yeah yeah but
like if you're you know you're uh you
need that you need that edge
man i've been advocating because like
ramen ramen is that one japanese dish
where before i moved to japan i was just
i was thinking oh i'm going to eat ramen
every [ __ ] week every day
i've had ramen three times the past week
though really but i didn't have ramen
for like months before that oh yeah yeah
i was saying like the last time i had
ramen before we went to this michelin
star ramen place uh was like i think a
year before a year before that's just
because i have like zero craving for
ramen because why would i have ramen
when i can have tsukimen right
like but the one dish that i haven't got
bored off though is a sushi like i eat
sushi at least one once a week really at
least once a week damn you eat more than
me
and i love sushi i probably go maybe
like yeah two or three times a month i
wish there was like a really quick and
easy one near my house i would probably
go i don't want to order it yeah no it
doesn't order well but like i i feel
like there's there's a few conveyor belt
sushi's near my place and it's just
perfect for lunch man it's it's like
100 yen because even like 100 yen sushi
which is like 80 80 cents for like one
piece of like salmon or something yeah
it's so good yeah honestly like my
experience with sushi in japan is that
you know you think you know i've also
you know melin's taking me to some
michelin star sushi places as well and
of course she has
only eats if there's michelin
she's like i don't see the michelin men
anyway i'm not going basically part of
the big reason why we've gone to more
michelin star places is because you know
melin suggested these places to us
where's buy it yeah which is how we
found the mid the the robin place which
is
recommended the ramen place and it
happened to be michelin star but uh
you know i i have tried like a few like
a lot of different sushi places of like
different price points and my honest
opinion is that
like sushi
you reach about like you know you reach
about like 30 dollars a meal for a sushi
which is about you know mid mid-range
sushi in japan right it's not cheap it's
not expensive and that's about as good
as it gets to me because you go you go
you can get sushi from like like thirty
dollars like a hundred dollars like two
hundred dollars gourmet yeah super
famous chefs out there like how dare you
yeah
and like my like my honest opinion is
that i've i've had the expensive sushi
and i'm just like
it's better but it's not that much
better than like the 30 sushi that i can
get that's how it always is though like
i find that the meals that are a little
more pricey than the the you know the
normal ones are generally like the the
nice ones and then when you get to the
stupid extravagant levels of prices just
like not that yeah
it's like a ten ten tenfold increase for
like a five to ten percent better meal
you know i i think i would argue that
like if you're ever gonna go to like
especially like the high high-end sushi
places which is all around tokyo then
like get something that you could only
get in that high-end restaurant yeah so
like because i remember i took uh my
friend luke to
like the the really high-end sushi place
because he's never been to like a
high-end sushi place so i took him to
the one in um harajuku yeah and it was
like 400 bucks between the two of us
so it's like really something
but that place has like uh
uh i i think i don't know if you guys
have been to it but like it's the one
where you can have like the nine
different types of uh sea urchin
different types of seeds yeah yeah so
they do this like especially
yeah so there's a special thing where
they do like nine different types of
seeds we're talking about sushi
and you get
and you get like my stomach's just yeah
and you get like taste tests like the
different types of sea urchin from like
different parts of japan and around the
world and stuff and like that is like
cool because i'm literally salivating
i'll give you 0
like that is cool because i've only ever
seen that in that store like yeah it's
expensive but that is an experience that
you can only get in that store you can't
go to like a [ __ ] sushi chain right
but like if you're just gonna go to a
high-end sushi place and just order
[ __ ] salmon on rice then like there's
no point there's no difference like
you're not the average person is not
that much of a sushi snob where they're
gonna be like oh this is this isn't the
high grade salmon that they're using
it's just like even if it's high grade
salmon it's like a like five percent
increase in how better the taste is and
sushi is basically just it's rice it's
the fish it's the wasabi and it's just
like the soy sauce they put on top and
like it's basically you just have to
like make sure the ratios are right and
then there's only yeah and then there's
only like so much the fish can be fresh
right yeah at which point do we at which
point do we just like say hey you just
can't make this taste any better with
the ingredients you're given right
because unless you have like like 10
times the number of taste buds than the
average human like it's not going to
change exactly exactly like my my tongue
doesn't
like i'm not i'm not part of like
shokugeki or something i can't like
taste like the exact percentage of
salinity in the [ __ ] although i must
say when i did try the nine different
types of like uh sea urchin i was ready
to take my shirt off from how good it
was she's like oh i'm just i'm just an
unagi fan man it's my favorite food in
japan unagi it's the best yeah but see
like even like unagi right like after a
certain price range it's like oh no no
you can't you can't taste it no no no
yeah but like that's why like
if you just go to an aggie place it's
kind of expensive and aggie in general
but i mean like even like the the lower
lower price point ones i'm always like
satisfied yeah exactly and i think it's
somewhat good for you so that's good is
it it's it's not terrible it's not
terrible it's got a lot of like uh you
know a lot of good uh omegas um those
fishy oils but they are also going
extinct as well that's the reason why
their prices well it's not like japan
eats like 80 percent of the world's eels
or something something like that but
then they there's tons of eels from
other countries it's it's it's 80 it's
like most of japan's eels they have like
nearly yeah yeah they're like almost all
gone that's why they're just getting
more expensive yeah
so i saw like a whole business insider
video on that yeah because they because
japan has a thing of like we don't want
to import foreign things it's lower
quality well they're starting like eel
farms now yeah they're where they they
import the eels like as babies from
other countries yeah and grow them in
japan like they're like they're japanese
it's just like japanese eels yeah
yeah which is why
which is why i realized you know when
you go to a restaurant and they serve
you this like really expensive dish or
really expensive meats right that
doesn't necessarily mean it tastes any
better because a lot of it's like a lot
of more expensive
meats weren't that expensive in history
right so you know the taste hasn't
changed like for example lobsters you
know they yeah they you know that they
used to be like peasant food yeah they
used to be like peasant food or you know
food without someone laughing in the
office tide pods used to be peasant food
now gourmet
salmon used to be present food as well
yeah
[Applause]
it's something like peasant food you
know
a sushi restaurant